laurent et protestants il va au temple
parce qu'il est amoureux de la fille du
pasteur
marie-pierre va à la messe tous les
dimanches et anime le catéchisme dans le
collège de son fils slimane et musulmans
il fait le ramadan pour faire plaisir à
sa mère mais il ne croit pas vraiment en
dieu
gabriel juifs fervent éteint la lumière
et ne touche plus un appareil électrique
dès le vendredi soir et tous le samedi
c'est shabbat sofia dit qu'elle est
catholique parce qu'elle est baptisé
mais elle va à l'église que pour les
enterrements et les mariages
andré est athée et quand on lui parle de
dieu ça lui donne des boutons georges
demande si dieu existe et salle angoisse
parce qu'ils voudraient bien qu'il y ait
quelque chose après la mort alain juifs
ils ne croient pas en dieu mais il
fréquente la synagogue de son quartier
parce qu'ils apprécient le rabbin lucien
est agnostique dieu ne l'intéressent pas
noémie croit en la réincarnation et
pense que dans une vie antérieure elle
était une fleur abdel en revanche pris
cinq fois par jour en direction de la
mecque quand son travail lui en laisse
le temps
pour la majorité des français la
religion est secondaire elle fait
simplement partie de leur culture ou de
leur passé pour d'autres c'est
primordial et ça conditionne beaucoup
d'action dans leur vie mais il s'agit de
leur vie privée et ça ne regarde que la
france est un pays laïc ce qui veut dire
que l'état et les institutions
religieuses sont séparés le pouvoir doit
laisser la liberté de religion à chacun
d'eux doit favoriser aucune religion et
n'affiche et dans les bâtiments publics
aucun signe religieux les membres de la
fonction publique doivent être
totalement neutre en matière religieuse
c'est très particulier à la france et ça
date de la fin du 19e et du début du 20e
siècle en 1881 jules ferry ministre de
l'éducation
décide que l'école est obligatoire
gratuite et laïque
avant cette date c'est l église qui
domine l éducation et donc les
consciences en 1905
une majorité républicaine votre la
séparation de l'église et de l'état
l'état ne finance plus l'église
catholique ne peut plus le clergé ne
considère plus le catholicisme comme la
religion officielle du pays mais la
laïcité vient de plus loin de l'idée
développée par les philosophes des
lumières qui au xviie siècle considéré
que la raison devait prévaloir sur la
spiritualité et que la religion figé
l'homme dans un ordre établi l'empêchant
de s'épanouir et de se libérer
la révolution de 1789 a été porteuse de
cette idée et s'est faite contre la
noblesse mais aussi contre le clergé qui
dominait la société depuis des siècles
et régler la vie des français depuis la
révolution et en dehors des périodes de
restauration et dans pire le pouvoir
entretient avec l'église des rapports de
méfiance
aujourd'hui malgré quelques intégristes
religieux qui voudraient que leur dieu
s'impose à tous
l'idée de la laïcité est largement
acceptée même par les responsables
religieux qui s'emploie à la respecter